[Music]
a dentist has been found guilty of
damaging patients teeth in order to
boost profits oh damn a crooked mechanic
yeah
he's breaking people's crowns wow this
uh wisconsin dentist was found guilty of
health care fraud and other charges
after he intentionally damaged his
patients teeth to boost profits raking
in millions
from his scheme maybe the problem
there's not enough population in
wisconsin so they're like how am i going
to increase my customer base when i only
got a handful of customers in this small
town repeat customers exactly
logically it kind of makes sense it does
though it does what what's his scheme
yeah okay so prosecutors get them a lot
of candy
[Laughter]
that's all it is get them with their
kids give them for coming here's a 50
pack of kitkats
uh prosecutors say this guy's name is uh
scott carmolli he's 61 years old
convicted of five counts of healthcare
fraud and two counts of making false
claims about his client's treatments um
he had routinely drilled or broken his
client's teeth on purpose charging them
for additional treatment services to fix
the damage he had just done what so he
wasn't even lying about the damage he
would just be like oops that was right
again imagine like
the dancers like cleaning your [ __ ] or
something like that and be like and
actually damaging it and then being like
oh my god you have a damaged tooth oh
yeah you have a drilled tooth
how'd that drill get out
you've been chewing some drills
so as a result carmali's profits
ballooned with the dentist going from
making 1.4 million dollars and
installing 434 crowns in 2014 to 2.5
million dollars in 2015 installing over
1 000 crowns this one made a million
already i'm pretty impressed by his in
wisconsin yeah dude
he's killing it yeah that's not bad
right he's shooting wisconsin that
shitty ass state
kind of like dumbass
billionaire dude
he's jeff bezos how many [ __ ] houses
that would be already according to
prosecutors in 2015 carmeli began
pressuring his clients into getting
unnecessary crowns a dental procedure
where a tooth-shaped cap is placed on a
damaged tooth he would drill or break
his client's teeth and send x-rays of
the intentional damage to insurance as
before photos to justify the crown
procedures
so what um
how did he get caught well one client a
guy named tadeshi testified that carmeli
pressured him into getting two crowns in
one appointment despite tadeshi
believing that his teeth were fine it
seemed excessive but i didn't know any
better he was the professional so i
trusted him some of the patients that
carmeli badgered into unnecessary
procedures were also vulnerable to
prosecutors some of these patients were
extremely vulnerable individuals in
abusive relationships recently widowed
survivors of cancer and living paycheck
to paycheck he know how to target
scrounging to afford kofi a copay is
required this fool's a psychopath yikes
he made 1.5 million you know like not
enough for him
actually between 2016 to 2019 he
build more than 4.2 million for crowns
wow performing more crowns than 95
percent of dentists in wisconsin during
that time oh see that's because they
didn't have yelp back then this is 2016.
never mind yelp was really bad back then
though really bad what's the average
cost of one crown i have no idea seven
thousand dollars
i know like a a dental implant is like a
thousand per tooth crowns are expensive
i don't know about that they're pretty
expensive right what's retail on the
crown you know anybody i don't know
look on offer i figured out like
something that was just enough
affordable yeah and you could convince
them and according to testimony from an
insurance company executive while an
average wisconsin dentist performs fewer
than six crowns for every 100 patients
carmeli's rate exceeded more than 32
crowns per 100 clients and that's why
they keep all those snaps
yeah statistically they're like wait a
minute it's funny that's two closest
insurance companies are the ones that
find out because they're like you
[ __ ] with my money
well i love that that they could see the
anomalies like that that's dope yeah by
the end of 2020 he had over 6.8 million
dollars worth of assets with vacation
homes in wisconsin and arizona i wonder
if his his [ __ ] local access
commercial is like i'm the crown king
come see me
that would hide it better almost you
know it's like why do i have an inflated
amount of people taking [ __ ] crowns
because i'm the crown guy
everybody comes to me
[Laughter]
more people than wisconsin even has
the stats don't lie
i'm the crowd there's carson don't even
have any teeth
how do you do that nearly 100 of
carmeli's former patients have sued him
for medical malpractice with those cases
set to begin once his federal criminal
proceedings are over
so he's going to be in some trouble for
a long he's [ __ ] dude yeah he's so
[ __ ] up right so yeah oh and it says
here
his uh schemes were eventually unearthed
when he sold his dental practice in 2019
while reviewing his files the new owners
noted the high rate of crown procedures
had done and reported him to authorities
so it's actually the people that bought
his dental business damn
he got got
he thought he thought he was too slick
oh [ __ ] someone kicks it it says
i'm gonna give him all the crowns he
runs into a former patient as a cellmate
yeah he goes you know what i have 50
crowns in my mouth
he's like i only do 32 teeth
i got 50 crops but your teeth look
amazing
it said uh the health and safety of
patients is my highest concern as a
doctor as medical professionals we take
an oath to do no harm to our patients
which is why i felt the ethical
obligation to report activity that i
believed to be suspicious wrote the new
owner where's dope man spoken like a
true snitch
you think you would rat if you were the
dentist that found out okay let's say
you're the guy right you're you're the
guy who's committing all these crimes
and i'm the new guy trying to buy your
office and then in the negotiation
you're asking for more than you [ __ ]
deserve
yeah i'm trying to [ __ ] you over i mean
if you did some [ __ ] that was
unnecessary but if you gave me a [ __ ]
good deal if you gave me a good deal
that's probably where you [ __ ] die
you might try to overlook it or just
like oh it's fine this guy probably
thinks he can get it with everything try
to [ __ ] the uh other business owner over
and he got [ __ ] himself that's what he
gets because the new guy who bought it
is never going to be able to match the
previous numbers so it's not a win for
him so he is going to expose him or else
it's going to look like it was a bad
investment he's going to go oh man i did
way worse than what the [ __ ]
i only made a million and he said he
made four
am i bad
am i no good
i mean how many how many dentists out
there are making a million a year no no
you have to own your own practice some
some of those guys rake it in but maybe
it's a 24-hour dental place or it's
constant customers
this guy's doing 24 hour shifts just
[Laughter]
365. before he's going down the streets
and he's just wearing a mask and
punching people in the face breaking
their people at 3am are like i need a
crown right now
i can't wait i'm looking on a
dentalpost.net that does a salary survey
type in wisconsin too
i have every state for example
california on average it says 160 000 a
year salary if i go down to wisconsin
yeah that's what i thought
wisconsin is 200 000. also it is more
over there that's because of that guy he
[ __ ] brought that [ __ ] away
you started the crown trend it kind of
works out yeah
it kind of makes sense does kind of make
sense i think actually let me see if no
vermont has 254 000 which means vermont
you got some illegal activity going
on rhode island 258 thousand why the
[ __ ] these small ass places you know
what it is too is is like different
places also have different insurance
like insurance pays for a lot like a lot
of people here don't have dental like if
you have dental like if you it's like
all right you know what i mean you just
get [ __ ] done without even thinking here
it's like you gotta weigh the pros and
cons and the costs down in mexico
[Laughter]
just for cleaning because i gotta go to
tijuana i kept the uh i kept the job
that had full health benefits like eye
teeth whatever right because i was
starting to feel
my teeth hurt my wisdom teeth was
growing out and then my uh the dentist
was like you're probably gonna need that
pulled out in
in the next six months to a year so i'm
like thank god if i get hired into this
place after after six months probation
when you're a full-time employee they're
gonna take care of all that so i was
like yes and that costs thousands bro if
you're making like
you're making like 12 bucks an hour like
thousands is like dude that's like a
whole month or two of your pay right so
like
that [ __ ] was covered and i was like so
hella thankful and then after that i
quit but like dude nice you know me like
as you should that's you gotta do that
[ __ ] well i i quit to pursue jk you know
what i mean that was my last job job but
then i could have stayed with them as a
thank you but like i don't know man
you gotta get yours you do the right
thing yeah what else are you gonna do
you know but i'm just wondering when
we're gonna get dental for working here
well you're not an employee so i don't
know where where where
hold up
hey when you get married bro you get
some nice insurance benefits that's what
i'm on brad you guys get wow what
happened dog i'm cause you're a white
bird oh because oh cause she's a health
care professional and she was a baby and
she might she might i don't know well no
molly don't don't ask about it yeah he's
married to a doctor dude it's fine my
lady's at a a clinic though so i don't
get you know the same full things yeah
but you know we'll see we still got time
we're trying to figure it out there's
big hospitals in vegas that need what
your your girl does i [ __ ] up man
what a stable job girl
we're with
foreigners i have nothing dad mine's
australian
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you